so now how do I use that yeah remember
what I wanna do is I want to shred the
equivalents this is the first part of
the pressure I want to show the
equivalence between these two integrals
where do we start
okay so I'm gonna take I won okay I'm
just gonna take it as it is and then I'm
going to reflect it across now just
quickly I told you those reflection you
can kind of see it where am i reflecting
across it looks to me like I've used
this axis of well it's not really an
axis of symmetry is it because it's the
most symmetrical function but when you
take these two together right that's
where I'm flipping across right that's
right for you guys so that's why zero
and H they are the same distances away
from that that midpoint okay so I'm
reflecting this down from North supplier
boundaries stay put right but I'm going
to reflect it across PI on to that's
where I'm gonna go that's halfway
between these boundaries yeah so
therefore this is going to become PI
minus X all the X's become playing -
excellent right and then you've got one
plus cos square Phi minus X and that's
all the thing integrand change it's
still with respect to the same variable
it's not where there's X of Pi minus X
thankfully all right now this looks good
you're sick smooth what am I gonna need
to change I'm gonna have to change the
sign right now you can do this through a
graph or if you want you can do is
purely algebraically you can do this
through the identities this is a
compound angle right this is a sine a
minus B yeah so therefore sine of a
minus B is equal to sine
a cause they take away yeah whichever
one you like really okay what's sine PI
sine PI it's zero right and you've got a
negative there's of sine X what's
cosplay negative one then that's exactly
what I wanted okay but not only am I
gonna have to change the sign I'm gonna
have to change the cosine right so I say
okay well let's just do this again again
and like I said you can do this
algebraically you can shift PI units and
then you can reflect that if you like
but this is just as quite easy I think
this is not gonna be side cause my gosh
this is gonna be pause pause plus sine
sine yes told me get what quiz players
maybe one tell me again what side
players is the right and you're like oh
hold on this ah but I don't have a
cosine I have a cosine square right so
and this by the way I will point out B
that this is a proof this entry comes
from in exam I think I mentioned to you
before and this is a critical spot where
don't fudge and don't miss out this step
okay so I'm gonna go north to PI all my
numerator everything is looking sweet
because I just showed that that's the
case but on my denominator right this is
not just one plus plus square X it's
actually 1 plus negative cos and that's
what's being squared
yeah don't take that shortcut don't just
write cos squared if you just write that
then you're just you're just
regurgitating what the question is told
you right you didn't have to understand
anything to write that so this is a
minor difference but it's an important
one with respect X you happy with that
and I'll just tidy it up so that I get I
to
that's just pasta because
oh yeah okay so you're introducing a
negative that will then end up changing
seems to me fine but there are just two
problems number one of problems but
first looking to be able to take
advantage of that property that's the
first thing sure is that that what you
just said is not that property yeah and
secondly I think you are just
introducing a double negative as far as
I can see which it's like why introduce
to donate if I could just use it we got
the negatives which is why I'm gonna
tell pasta okay yes let's keep moving
coming okay now what was pop - well
puppies rather yeah you wanted to take a
son okay so let's quickly have a go at
this is puppy I 1 plus I 2 just given
the time and because I think you can see
it and take a little bit of a short time
here what I've got is a pair of
integrals same boundaries same
denominators yes
do you agree with that yeah why didn't
you just use IG when you split it up and
get by two equals
- I wonder that is what I'm about to do
patients are pella ok so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say look I could
actually just like notice right if the
boundaries are the same the denominators
are the same for variable integrations
the same the only thing that changes is
the numerators right so therefore I'm
going to say from naught to PI okay but
then what I've got on the numerator is
going to be X sine X plus PI minus X
sine X do you see that well it's just
the two new ribs I just combined them
into one and then you've got this
denominator down here are you happy with
that
okay now what's really about this is
because look at what the neurons do the
combined the emotions right you've got
an X sine X there and then you've got a
minus X sine X so these two are just
going to cancel cancel what are they
going to leave you with on the numerator
PI sine X now that pie is just constant
so just bring it out the front which
leaves you with this okay put your
integration hat on what's that look like
now maybe it's not entirely obvious to
you but this is going to become tan
inverse to make it clear right because
it certainly wasn't to me clear - clear
to me the first time I'm gonna make a
substitution which is suitable so I'm
going to certainly let u equal to cos x
cuz then I've got a 1 plus u squared on
the denominator if that's the case of
course I need do you okay now I have a
sine X in there so I'm just going to put
this minus sign over here and then I've
got some boundaries right I better
change my batteries so when x equals 0
what are you going to even
cause of 0 which is 1 and when x equals
pi use going to equal cos of Pi which is
negative 1
yeah so whatever got ya I'm gonna say hi
from new boundaries ah 1 2 maybe 1
yep then you've got the sine X on the
top is gonna give me that negative do
you on DX that I want to change my
variables of integration
what's my denominator 1 plus G square
and then the DX that was already there
which cancels ok suggestions we've got
some definite integral properties we
could use here right there's a negative
sign I don't really want there to be a
pest
oh so some boundaries that seem like
they're in a reader looking order what
am I gonna do yeah I'm going to use the
reverse property this integral has
actually been in red river a backwards
interval so I'm going to take that
negative sign out the front which just
promptly changes the order of my
boundaries right and this is just well
that's about as textbooks as you get for
a attend a messenger all right so this
is the umpire outside of tan inverse of
you from negative 1 to 1 okay top
boundary first was 10ms of 1 that's
final form take away what's tan inverse
of negative 1 well I could have in fact
if I was even lazier
I could have noticed this is an odd
function so I could have doubled it and
gone from 0 to 1 which I've just done
but anyway I've already gotten this far
so that's negative 504 but you can see
in here PI over 4 plus 9 for player 2
which gives me the PI squared untii then
I was after
ok now we're pretty much done the last
bit is really just kind of a how to
break the trivial but it's a really nice
way to tell you something for Part C was
to evaluate I won right but if I just
carry on directly from this line I know
that I 2 is I want so this is what I get
just carrying on
from the previous question so therefore
I one is okay that was the easiest mark
in the home paper right so that's kind
of cool because look at this just look
back at the original question you're
like a lot a mess
do I really have to do that by pots
substitution whatever okay I don't even
know if you can I don't know if we have
the tools yet to do that analytically
but because it's definite integral we
can take advantage off and you can see
how many properties we took advantage of
just by going three dollars okay